hi
let's talk religion so as some of you
know I'm a student of religions but my
area of expertise is in fact Islam and
Sufism and not what is Sufism you may
ask and that's a very good question I
think when a lot of people think Sufism
they get this image and technically yes
that is Sufism but it's in fact a very
specific ritual by a specific order of
Sufism called the nevla via that's based
in Turkey and Sufism is in fact a much
bigger and more complex than this and is
a much more significant part of Islamic
history than many tend to believe now
many people tend to describe Sufism as
the inner dimension of Islam or Islamic
mysticism or associated with ascetic
individuals living in caves in seclusion
in the wilderness but this is in fact
it's a great oversimplification of the
subject and Sufism is a tradition that
has taken on many many forms and diverse
forms throughout history to explain it
properly we'll have to go way back
all the way back to the very inception
of the Islamic religion and the
immediate aftermath after the death of
the Prophet Muhammad in the years
following his death and asked the
Islamic religion was spreading
throughout the world many people
struggled with how to apply the new
religion and answer questions like what
it is and how it should be lived and in
this early phase a lot of different
traditions emerged one was the legal
tradition on his fik which established
the diverse legal system we know today
as Sharia you know that thing that
everyone's so afraid of and this was a
way to establish the right way to live
as Muslim people and as a society to
other traditions that emerged were
theology or Kalam and also philosophy or
fanciful which was inspired by Greek
philosophy and tried to apply a lot of
those ideas to the written sources of
the Koran and the hadith and lastly
there was Sufism known in Arabic as - so
it's difficult to know exactly when
Sufism appeared but we know that in the
eighth and ninth centuries the word Sufi
was used to describe a certain group of
individuals in and around Baghdad
that lived extremely pious and ascetic
lives and would often wear rich sheep
and and is a simple clothing in fact
many believed that the word Sufi comes
from the Arabic word tzuf which means
wool and referred to the kind of
clothing that they would wear at the
time now it's important to note that
these different traditions were in no
way exclusive being a Sufi did not mean
that you rejected shaadi or wasn't
interested in philosophy but these
tended to blend together and was open
sort of part of the early Islamic
history also Sufism should definitely
not be described as a branch of Islam as
like Sunni or Shia because Sufis
throughout history has belonged to both
of these denominations now these early
ascetic individuals would lay the
groundwork what would become a hugely
diverse and influential tradition within
Islam one of the most famous of these
early Sufis was in fact a woman named
Atta be Allah the Weah or Rabi al bara
and she's often described as a very
beautiful woman who turned her back
completely on the world and spent all
her time in devotion and love for God
now this focus on unconditional love
would later become a staple of Sufism at
least some branches within Sufism and it
is perhaps best expressed in one of her
famous sayings if I adore you out of
fear of hell burn mean he'll if I adore
you out of desire for paradise lock me
out of paradise but if I adore you for
yourself alone do not deny me your
eternal beauty now these are the Sufis
eventually evolved in different
directions and are sometimes divided
into two very general categories which
is sober Sufis and ecstatic Sufis a very
famous of the latter is a man by the
name of Mansur al-hallaj was a very
controversial figure both during his
lifetime but also to some degree still
today in a very popular story it is said
of how Lodge after intense spiritual
practice entered an ecstatic state where
he ran out on the streets of Baghdad
shouting Ana al-haq
which is usually translated to I am the
truth now truth or al haq is in fact one
of the so-called 99 names of God and
thus what collage was essentially saying
is
I am God and this of course shocked the
authorities at the time who executed him
in a rather nasty way for daring to
associate himself with God but according
to many Sufis what he was doing was
actually quite the opposite
what halat had done through his intense
spiritual practice was to completely
annihilate himself and become immersed
in the reality of God when he said on
al-haq or I am the truth he wasn't
associating himself with God but he had
taken the eye out of the picture
completely and there was only God left
this to Sufis was in fact the ultimate
sign of humility and which is quite the
opposite of what the authorities thought
and this would also become a main tenant
of their practice it's kind of similar
to the philosophy that Jim Carrey's
obnoxiously trying to convey in every
single interview nowadays in spite of
its great diversity especially later on
there were a few unifying practices and
teachings that can be said to
characterize Sufism generally one of
these is referred to as jihad al nafs or
struggle against the self now the nafs
is a complex word that is usually
translated to everything from ego to
self or lower self it's the part of us
that we usually identify with the eye or
the me so to speak
according to Sufis the nafs is actually
a veil that separates us from God and
thus it should be tamed and eventually
taken out of the equation completely the
goal here is complete annihilation of
the self or not known as fauna in which
the veil is lifted and reality as it is
is revealed what this actually means
this is a debate that's been discussed
throughout history and there are a lot
of different people who have very
different opinions about it but this
also leads us to another unifying
characteristic of Sufism which is
practice how is this fanaa
achieved the most common practice is
something known as thicker meaning
remembrance you've probably seen videos
of dhikr with added dance music on top
as it often involves very intense bodily
movements the curd is a kind of
meditation where the names of God or or
the first half of the Shahada there is
no god but God is repeated over and over
again for long periods of time there are
kinds of vicar that are very intense and
physical there are
that are very melodic and also those
like that of the naqshbandiya order that
is completely quiet what they all have
in common is the intent which is
remembrance of God and thus also
forgetfulness of the self or the nufs
another famous practice is something
known as Samar which means listening and
these rituals often include music or
recitation of poetry or the Quran and as
kind of a similar function to the Vicker
but here ecstatic states are reached
through listening to these things music
or recitation famous examples of Sam I
include the whirling dervishes of the
novella via that I mentioned in the
beginning and also qawalli music made
famous by people like Nosferatu leak on
a Sufism grew in popularity it started
to eventually become more systematized
it's about its teachings and its
practices around the turn of the first
millennium Sufism can be said to have
taken the form that to some degree it
still holds today and this was mainly
for two reasons one was the intellectual
systematization z' of its teachings and
wider acceptance as a result brought on
by people like abu talib al marcus
abdullah mongol salami and perhaps most
famously abba hamid al-ghazali it's not
really historically correct to say that
there existed a Muslim orthodoxy there
was not position to Sufism but
al-ghazali's certainly was one of the
main factors in ensue films wider
acceptance throughout the Muslim world
in his book the revival of the religious
sciences he said to have successfully
created a synthesis between Sufism Fick
our jurisprudence and column-based
theology and which resulted in it's like
I said the wider acceptance also around
this time the practitioners of Sufism
began to organize themselves into
tarukas or orders from tariqa means way
in basically or path many of these
orders still remain today and can differ
dramatically in terms of practice or
philosophy some of the earliest and most
famous of these include the Cod area
shoddily and Naqshbandi raffia and so on
all these orders usually formed around
the Sheikh or a saint which they call in
Arabic wali or friend of God more
properly translated and the teachings
that he is associated with so the
kadriye was formed around a man named
abdulqadir Gilani and the shoddily
around a bajas on our shoddily for
example and the veneration of these
saints is also a great characteristic of
Sufism generally and they're grave sites
or shrines often become a place of
pilgrimage it is thought that these
Saints possess a kind of divine grace
called Baraka which can be received by
just being close to him while he's still
alive or after he's dead
by his gravesite or shrine as that
shrine still possessed some of that
Baraka the teachings and Baraka of these
saints is also passed down in the line
of succession called silsila which is
why the idea of the Sheikh is so
important in Sufism generally speaking
if you are practicing Sufi you need a
sheikh a spiritual master who will guide
you on the path his legitimacy is based
on the line of succession that usually
goes all the way back to the founder of
the order and eventually also to the
Prophet Muhammad himself there's a whole
lot to talk about when it comes to
Sufism and you know can't just fit into
one episode it's that episode we become
way too long so we're gonna have to
divide this into two episodes so I'm
gonna end this one here and I'll release
the next one next week so I'll see you
then
[Music]